thank you
[Music]
have you guys ever seen the movie uh The
Equalizer yes yeah Denzel let's go all
right okay okay it's just equalizer it
doesn't matter though is it good there's
equalizer two as well the first one is
better than the second the second one I
love Denzel so it's still cool yeah
doesn't that mean it is good if they
made a second one like it performed
pretty good people loved it yeah people
people enjoyed it yeah people enjoyed it
I don't remember versus like the little
things or whatever I thought that was
weird it's like John Wick but like at a
Costco that's the whole movie so it's a
black John Rick black John Wick and a
costume was it Costco or was it Like
Home Depot or something he works at like
a hardware store and then like the whole
movie takes place in nah nah nah and
it's not a good chunk a good action it's
gonna be like die hard imagine the lows
is the Continental for John Wick
is a lot more like Fast and the Furious
style uh action equalizes a lot more
like um like more realistic like more
like cleverness yeah but it's also like
uh what's that guy um Liam Neeson oh
take it it's like kind of like kind of
like taken yeah yeah I want to see
action movies in the Costco that'll be
sick dude watch The Equalizer [ __ ]
lunch lady [ __ ] giving out free
samples bust out [ __ ] that's
why I said Lowe's or Home Depot there's
no there's no samples yeah you go to the
pharmacist and [ __ ] they got [ __ ]
grenade just work best Barbers does have
a great day
no pharmacist just hungry so are you
excited for the third equalizer what
there's a third one they're making it
right now I am but it's also like when
Liam Neeson did the first take-in versus
the third taken you can see how much
older he is so he moves slower and also
like it's like how are you gonna lose
your family a third time you know what I
mean it is responsible now yeah yeah how
old is Denzel 60. oh I don't know he's
old enough where his son is pulling like
large movies you know what I'm saying
Johnson Washington so it's kind of like
67.
37 black don't crack man
speaking of black don't crack Angela
Bassett thank you oh yeah she's an
equalizer no but she's you just screamed
her name because she turned you on
I think I said it in a very very
respectable I so
get one have a good plot first one I
think had a good plot the SEC I'm simple
and unexpected oh okay don't tell me
that I'm gonna watch it I don't know the
plot for the third one so but something
happened while they were filming this
third one right now that almost sounds
like a better plot than what the real
one could be okay what happened so
they're filming equalizer 3 in Italy
right the head of catering dies he has
like a heart attack suddenly yeah oh no
so what happens is they end up uh I just
picture Italian man going oh no why are
these Americans eating the Domino's
Pizza
yeah because he made all this like
authentic real Italian [ __ ] ah we want
sabaro and if he's like oh no
Jason Jenny can you do a good Italian
accent
uh I believe you could do it yeah
say spaghetti like that uh tortillas
that's pretty good oh my God what is
that a bad one it's like an egg rolls
[Laughter]
I love to eat the balloon
orange chicken so I the head caterer
dies and then they end up arresting the
catering crew why do you think that
happened assassination whoa
he tried to [ __ ] poison the food and
kill Denzel oh that's pretty crazy
that's that might be even better but in
the catering crew killed the chef
nobody they're suspects for it nobody
killed anyone but they did get arrested
for something oh oh so what happened is
with salt in the food yeah too much
oregano
they um they arrested them because they
when that kid caterer died they found
some like little bits of cocaine in his
pockets and then they they ended up
searching where the catering crew was
staying and they found 120 grams of coke
but hold on hold on these catering guys
they work hard bro yeah they need
all-nighters they need it they gotta do
a little bump to keep them going the
catering guys need to do this and come
on it's a Denzel movie if you guys
remember watching that movie Flight or
whatever he does cooking all the time I
think it's just like a wow you know it's
on par it's just everybody on set is on
cocaine but they just caught the Kaden
crew I thought that they all got
arrested because Italy takes their food
so serious that the catering crew was
just like you brought dominoes to this
country yeah the head Gator guy was
Italian right they exported Domino's
Pizza yeah
Italian police was like breadsticks
sticks into the bakery are we eating
Domino's for lunch now dude let's do
that that's usually how it starts that's
always Joe repeats something like three
times
it's pretty good are you tempted to make
it a pizza day I don't know because
lunch right now is at not train so I I
like I ate Vietnamese food last night
again should we do a pizza and Coca-Cola
in uh yeah you want to get pizza on the
side of the [ __ ] yeah yeah we're gonna
order downtown but can I get a pizza on
the side I'm not now at Pizza Hut I like
Pizza Hut better do you guys like pizza
why keep on bringing up dominoes uh it's
just funnier okay that's right it's a
better punchline so they found 120 grams
of cocaine is that a lot by the way
someone who yeah I don't know I never
did Coke somebody who slangs uh excuse
me I only smoked crack thank you very
much it's a small 120 dub sacks pretty
much right
120 grams yeah it's like 120 dubstack I
guess so yeah it seems like a lot yeah
140 grams of cocaine is is like probably
a lot I mean it's not like [ __ ] like
a brick of like a Pablo Escobar no not a
kilo yeah this isn't where like narcos
come in the deas there and it's like
this is a big bus yeah but still yeah it
looks like only in crack form
it's snooty watch me Google
120 grams sounds like a lot I never
played with that so protein powder is a
good after a certain amount of uh like
quantity then it's like you're legally
trafficking yeah legally like selling
they think you're a dealer but you said
120 grams and not in ounces so it must
be just in grams and on everyone
dispersed it yeah so like they they
ended up searching the the entire cruise
like living a little hotels or whatever
they're saying and they just I guess
everywhere somewhere they just found
that many of them so maybe they were the
ones that were supplying Coke to the
rest of the production probably whoa
well you know I'm sure I feel like as I
got older I didn't realize how many
people just do Coke regularly there's a
lot yeah I I feel the same way one time
me and Tiffany went to like this little
like friends party and they're older
dudes they're like 35 36 maybe actually
no they're like 40s and they're like in
the industry and we're walking around
and people are doing coke on a [ __ ]
mirror and they're just passing around
so casually and we're all like what the
[ __ ] is this what people it felt like a
movie one of the dudes we used to buy
ecstasy from in high school he uh worked
as a customs agent
so that's how you would just get it in
so easily he was a customs agent yeah
holy [ __ ] it was so easy for him you
still have his content no because he's
the one that's like the in charge of
whether or not things pass or not you
know yeah so he's just like oh he's
getting a lot of coke though
it's like a thousand pills at a time a
gram is like 100 100 to 150 bucks in the
US
also like a 120 of those it's like a
cheese one of those yeah that's a good
amount that is a nice eight ball I hear
people say eight ball how much is it bro
3.5
whoa right yeah I don't know is it yeah
why they call it eight ball then
it's an eighth I think of a oh it's
because it's a magic ball that's gonna
tell you either to do stuff or not do
stuff yeah because every time I sit here
eight ball I think of the [ __ ] magic
eight ball am I a child I think it's an
eighth I think it's an eighth I forgot
yeah it's been a whale yeah 26. well
because 26 grams 20 yeah is about an
ounce so I don't know if they do Coke
and ounces though it's like I only know
weed measurements yeah I think
everything's in grams right yeah the
metric system yeah Graham Stefan's the
most efficient probably it's probably
not like a obviously like tons of
different movie sets there's definitely
Coke somewhere right yeah every single
one I bet I'll bet you there's 120 grams
of cocaine on every [ __ ] movie Set
yep no [ __ ] because if that's like
fifteen thousand dollars worth of Coke
but then you got like
these are not like you know people can't
afford it you know it's zombie would you
know it's a Denzel all these [ __ ]
actors they probably got hella Coke in
their [ __ ] suitcase and [ __ ] dude I
know welders that that work overnight
and they all casually just do Coke all
the time like roofers roofers do the
same [ __ ] yeah or the truck drivers
math keeps you awake that's probably too
hardcore for something
there's a lot of jokes about Roofing
guys
I think you get itchy with meth Coke you
don't get itchy oh so you don't want
someone working on your roof and going
ah and then they dropped the hammer yeah
ah Jason Cheney's just dropping little
bombs and knowledge on them dropping
little eight balls on us yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah you know Jason hey what's up
what's up you got some Hoagies drop some
coke facts those nasal cavities look
like they know what's up I was just
watching not a movie but why'd you make
fun of my noses yeah I was being
descriptive oh look at your [ __ ] nose
man I got a flat nose I can't get a lot
of a hundred dollar bills up this one
I've tried that you could put 200 bills
one of your holes bigger than the other
one though it is it is thank you for
pointing out my non-symmetrical face I'm
sorry you just I just felt attacked I'm
sorry it's okay it's doing crowd work
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I'll take
your apology but it seems like you do
know a lot about cocaine wouldn't I I
just watched a lot right when I say that
you went like this
I use it that's allergies
[Laughter]
milligrams bro he's always got allergies
in this office
and nosebleeds and allergies in his
office you know what's funny like the
coke world is so different from like the
weed world right like weed people they
can't wait to tell you how much they
smoke weed and then they make a
connection like openly like oh you smoke
weed I smoke weed oh I got so high this
but I got so high during this concert
and I just want to share their highness
but then like Coke dudes they're like so
secret right they're like oh do you
party yeah I party and then they like
[ __ ] do it like but it has to be like
a party like a [ __ ] Hollywood
industry party where they're passing
that [ __ ] around but then they don't do
it openly or you gotta go to the
bathroom and [ __ ] but then we people are
just like hey you wanna [ __ ] hit this
all in the open it's so different but I
feel like there's a coolness too with
the coke like if you go to the bathroom
together I feel like they they bond it's
a secret bonding yeah and then they're
like we know a secret you guys don't
exactly yeah you know that you know like
weeds like legalized right I know but
like even before cocaine's really
illegal right I feel like even before
there was a stigma for people who did
Coke like or any other harder drugs and
it had to be a secret it's funny
was openly like people just couldn't
[ __ ] stop talking about their weed
like life yeah it is strange because
even when uh weed was viewed like Coke
in high school there's already High
Times like the magazine yeah like that
was those lifetimes the lifestyle it's
it's true it's like a whole thing people
got weed shirts with like [ __ ] hats
they walk around like hey look I smoke
weed you don't have lines of coke shirts
and [ __ ] and like hats that are like
[ __ ] a line of powder you know you're
doing a bunch of coke you just have a
bunch of business ideas with your homies
yeah that's exactly how it works man
every time hey we should do this man
Aiden Johnson was built business ideas
right now dude the crazy thing is that I
feel like when you're growing up with
weed you hear about it a lot people talk
about it a lot with Coke it just [ __ ]
appears one day yeah like someone just
has it one day and without context
they're just like you want some and then
you're just like huh yeah but you know I
always feel like the way you you first
do it too is you walk into a room
because you just went into that corner
of the party there's like four people
there they closed the door behind you
you're like this is how it goes down but
it's not like weed with weed every you
hear about it a ton before you see it
you can smell it and you never really
have hear like Coke stories it's always
like yeah like weed stories nobody's
ever like oh my god I've never done
cocaine me neither and Coke stories
aren't funny should we do it it's always
hilarious should we try cocaine the
closest thing I did was smoke a rock of
crack
[Music]
so like I I smoked meth I did a lot of
very highly addictive drugs you tried it
all and then the day that I smoked I was
like
17 six 10 years old no actually I had my
first run-in and in my experience when I
was
13
someone put like [ __ ] what is that
angel dust and like they sprinkled crack
and then they made a joint out of it oh
and I didn't know this jeez but I
hallucinated like a [ __ ] I was
like 14 or something and I was like what
is in that that was the most dankest
weed I've ever had and they were all
laughing oh and then they were just like
yeah we put like extra [ __ ] in there and
I'm like man that was so good and then I
Never Had It Again fast forward I'm 17
years old right
my friends uh called it like moping or
something and they kept like let's go
get them up let's go get moped out and
I'm like I like riding mopeds let's go
and I thought I was like we're all gonna
go like steal mopeds or something and
ride motorbikes you know right and then
we're on the in this car and I'm all
like all right what's like what are we
gonna do like we're gonna [ __ ] steal
some mopeds or what and they're like
laughing at me and then they pulled out
this glass pipe and they just started
smoking crack and I'm like all right I
guess we're doing this
and I take a hit I take a hit and I
exhale and I feel like every little cell
in my body was getting massaged by a
gentle grandma and it was like oh what
the [ __ ] it's like I can't I came
without coming
I've never wanted to crack in my life
but you just saw the best [ __ ]
description
what because I took a hit and it smells
it smells like bleach and baking soda
it's the weirdest [ __ ] [ __ ] and then
you go you exhale and you're like
I understand skid row now because for
that moment because for that moment
you're like
I could be very empathetic at that time
in a [ __ ] dirty ditch right now and
don't even matter it doesn't matter
cause this is heaven like I could be
yeah I could be inside of a shopping
cart getting pushed downhill by a crazy
homeless man as long as I have crack in
my life and I'm like exhaling this crack
such a good product I'm like wow this
average advertisement is so good people
are relaxing right now the funny thing
is this this is a funny thing right it's
like when people are like I don't
understand why people do drugs it's like
do drugs and you'll understand why
people do drugs it is it's like if you
don't have nothing like this is like the
best Heavenly experience that you'll
ever [ __ ] have and then your life
is [ __ ] [ __ ] so you want to keep
going back it's too good you guys can't
do it yeah okay and then it only lasts
like three minutes after three minutes
it's [ __ ] quick and then that's why
people are like I need that again
because after three to like three to
five minutes max it's completely gone
yeah so uh before the video ends why
should people not do crack because it's
so [ __ ] good that it's addicting
it's amazing keep it on that side of the
thing it's still so good
we did we stayed up 72 hours [ __ ]
smoking so much that I never wanted it
ever again dude 72 hours at three minute
increments is a [ __ ] ton of smoking
yeah and then the dark side is you run
out of money and then you start doing
shady [ __ ] like crime and things like
that to make money and then you want to
feed your addiction and a lot of my
friends went to prison and thank
goodness you know like I think they
turned their life around most of them
but that's that's these that's the dark
side of the story so you wouldn't
recommend crack oh don't [ __ ] do it
but now I know now I know why we should
just edit all the dark stuff out
foreign